in some places you can tell what time of  year it is by which flowers are in bloom  in Yokohama it's which boats you see  passing through the harbor we have a  great view of the boats from my house on  poppy Hill it seems the whole country is  eager to get rid of the old and make way  for the moon but some of us aren't so  ready to let go of the past me I know  how much you miss your father I hope  you'll find someone  then maybe you won't need to raise those  flags anymore oh you come see this what  is it  Oh looks like someone's getting your  messages dad is that you he was a  captain on a supply ship but his ship  sank what's this  knots a boat I often see passing by this  might sound crazy but I think it's  answering your flags answering my flags  Hey  oh yeah baby she done  you